don't come guys before the video starts
misc do check out it's a brilliant up
for those who want to pray Salah and
share their words check them out now for
somebody to act like a Muslim behave
like a Muslim recite Quran a column like
a Muslim marry like a Muslim and all of
this was fake when I have kids children
come in and crying cuz they have a doubt
and we tried to help them you're gonna
come casually walk and they're not going
to turn the blind eye I said I'm gonna
come where I'm not gonna get here she
buffing sisters hope you guys are doing
well inshallah I'm gonna get straight
into the video has I now came out
yesterday and done this video let's
watch inshallah now following Abdullah's
and surah statements I can tell you all
that it is true there are certain points
of my life I was actually an agnostic
and I did push for marbella tools that
as well now with regards to Sarah she
has never been an agnostic in fact when
we went through those phases
Sahra helped us overcome our doubts and
problems on numerous occasions so with
regards arrest allegations i should be
addressing them very shortly in Shaba
particle of okay so her center has come
out and he said this and he said that
you know in a calm tone he said that
he's he at one point he left this nun
and he forced his wife to leave islam
and bomb and sisters look you know we
should just forgive him and forget and
let's just move on yeah that's what the
video is about well if I said that to
you
well just stay just now just test that
law statement really really you're gonna
come you're gonna come here in a calm
tone do a video and say I left this done
and I forced my wife to and we're gonna
say okay let's move on really
do you know what the hell you are
uttering do you know what look you came
clean no problem but you're not gonna
get
cooking for coming clean you're not
gonna get cookie don't expect from us to
come and say oh okay okay
and those people some of those who are
coming see brother forget and move on
while lying I urge don't message me I'll
be very harsh with you guys it's the
first time I've ever lost it and for a
reason it's policy something for those
people who are now automatically now
defending has enough yeah he can repent
if he's wronged his own self
he hates the sin he stops the sin and he
doesn't go back to the sin that's the
Commission of repentance yeah something
you could be a Turkish or not he can do
that but when you have wronged the
people no on the day of judgment before
you enter paradise you will be
questioned after the people that you
wronged in the grave you'll be
questioned about the people that you
wrong
did the deaths that you had you think
it's easy too strong in people and
moving away oh okay you all the efforts
that we have done I ever York Institute
I met be that who gave his life for this
Deen zakir naik the profits on mama
honey was send them the Sahaba the
Companions all of them who gave their
life for this Deen when I would be in
this office when I would see you job he
would have no money yes and I'm not
trying to praise Him we have our own
first don't praise us well why I'm
telling you do not play this you have no
idea when the hypocrites don't have a
double life we don't commit and we stay
away from major sin we're not perfect so
I don't know what to please us please
what my don't please us when each other
would have no shopping when in this
organization when we sell Salaam when we
set up Salaam for people like you who
have doubts
I'm hostage issue because of the
condition to come to us and we will help
you we will answer those doubts I always
spent in this studio man so we can help
people actually turn into Sarah I'm not
saying Sarah is incapable but she said
she was suicidal at one point I era what
they went through
we know I loved watch what they go
through and you're gonna come here and
tell us that you just for somebody and
that's it and that's it
all those efforts that everyone is went
through you're gonna come as I'm an
asset
well you was not now what
you was not now you disguise yourself as
a believer and infiltrated and portrayed
you're a con man for somebody to act
imagine if I came to you guys had said
all that time for the past four or five
years I was a non-muslim if you job came
if somebody else came you're gonna take
it lightly
all that time the question you're gonna
ask is how the hell did you fool us man
how did you act the words that you seen
but put and I use reciting how did you
do it we do not trust I think that you
say your repentance between you and your
Lord and Allah says in the Quran those
who believe and then this belief and
then believed again and then increased
they were about to displease and they
increased this is your test because you
believe number one at the beginning you
believer then you disbelieved then you
came to believe again now this is your
chest let's see if you're truly
repentant so you're gonna come here and
everything that we've done for the
youngsters for Dina look Tina Tokyo Sid
and Dena Adam solid food it should all
go see we didn't have a personal problem
with you even have nothing better to do
I have a personal problem with you the
reason why we do advises in public is
because all the efforts that we do in
helping our youngsters when I have kids
children come in and crying cuz they
have a doubt and we try to help them
you're gonna come casually walk and then
we're gonna turn the blind eye welcome
to say you know what that's a nice calm
forcing your wife you think we're gonna
turn a blind eye that you doesn't want
to turn a blind eye oh there first out
we did you're gonna just walk casually
and just see I was at this believer okay
yeah and I post my wife
we have information we know what you did
my hands are tied my hands are tied my
lips are sealed
not for too long not for too long
not for tongue can see I can't see it
more we know what you did we know what
you did so don't you dare dare come and
think that's gonna be a ride in the park
you if you do not shut your account I'm
looking in your face you can do whatever
you like if you cheat your word you will
change away surround we're here mister
reason why we set up sir
one of the reasons and people I are
beautiful above us an IRA we know the
struggles they went through
I know bombers they would not get it
paid a penny and they put their blood
sweat and tears yeah for someone like
you to come and infiltrate pretend
you're a Muslim yeah but most of you is
planning to come out with this think all
of a sudden God knows if he was coming
up with this yeah listen carefully even
though we hate you action for the sake
of allah subhanaw taala
and even though we have something
against you in our hearts yes we do
salam was set up to help people like
yourself and we are here yes we are here
for you as well we are angry and you
have no right tell about how dare you in
your video I'm not having a hub you have
a right to be annoyed with him you have
a right to be annoyed with him after
what you've done after what you've done
you you're gonna you're gonna comment
backbiting my happiness club how dare
you don't you dare utter a word to
anybody you have no right to be upset
give the double life we defended your
honor cruiser Sharia Court for it and we
will expose you cuz it surely a cause
for it the Sharia came to protect their
wealth the help the owner the uncle and
the religion of the people that's the
reason why for treason apostasy in the
stomach country not Midwest treason why
so harsh and even today in America it
was snow that he's run to Russia
mister reason why it's so severe and
this why these flippin double-faced
cowards clowns these X Muslim community
who's watching I know you're watching
you know what I'm talking about you
cowards yeah
you never talk about the suffering the
Muslims go through in the whole the
whole earth Burma Palestine Iraq you
double standard hypocrites are you gonna
talk about this now are you gonna talk
about somebody who left this time how he
was forcing his wives are you gonna talk
about mister the ex Muslim community
yeah let me talk about that cuz he
didn't talk about any loss video-making
supply hmm for those who are trying to
defend has enough for stainless for you
guys from scholars yes this is what
stamen goes Khmer takumu
you will laugh alaikum
as is your condition you shall be led
you know what this means you know when
you cut something behind the trunk come
into power trunk him into power because
certain idiots yes for for his nonsense
and certain individuals they are like
him Trump is a reflection of the people
that follow him so don't let this guy
I'm not seeing you have mercy on us want
us to Hume it's no problem but what you
did is not going to be just brushed on
the Rakata after than ever
Abdullah bin Masood said come me Murray
didn't lean Heidi
there you see bow how many people
intended good but didn't achieve it you
may have a sty this good you may have
with a good intention I want to do good
something but she whatever it was the
Jen's whatever it was about you I'm
telling you I'm telling you
fix your ways as Salaam we're here we're
here to fix things
yeah and I'm not playing the high horse
well llahi you you give me anxiety you
have given me anxiety anxiety
I don't thinking how did this guy get me
started I want to sit down and talk of
you and say brother what did you do that
I can prevent for myself
I'm scared fit for myself every day I
ask Allah o Allah forgive me if I'm
doing this for the wrong intentions all
my police forgive me from doing this for
the wrong intentions I'm scared of
standing in front of a line unless what
I say everything you did Ali was for the
people everything you did was tradition
that journey can you was a con man you
get your your neck is battle bar till
your marriage is battle your testimony
was baton he was doing rukia on the
people you was not a believer we can
expect anything from you for somebody to
go that low dangerous person you're an
evil person for not only yourself you
why are you forcing your wife why are
you forcing a man huh why forcing her
and it seemed that you trying to get rid
of Roxana cuz you got Sarah now yeah
repent repent to allah subhanho wa taala
yeah and come out full clean the way i
know flipping chapters chapter 1 2 3 4
come out clean the oma may forgive you
answer the questions of people's money
that people's Huck yeah
the rookie has terraced are you doing it
use do it he was mocking you didn't even
believe in it we cannot trust you and
don't you dare I've been hearing news
that you're trying to threaten me no my
no has us behind him yeah Marino has us
behind him don't get gassed and upset
because you couldn't come up with it and
it got exposed because I lost subhana WA
Ta'ala exposes allah subhanho wa taala
exposes this coming out you should be a
believer you should say you know what
yeah it meet allah subhanaw taala exist
it's a exposes don't you dare threaten
anybody and only reason the only way
this happening is because our youth have
doubts yeah we need to support any
organization we are salam would you guys
know what we do it one lie we believe in
this project i believe in this project
we studies project together and lot of
people let us down a lot of people let
us down
i believe in salam and I want to
continue salam because this right now
shows why this is needed ayah rather
they do a beautiful job for somebody to
act like a muslim behave like a muslim
recite quran a column do rock you like a
muslim marry like a muslim and all of
this was fake you guys thinking really
careful because you know why because you
guys don't understand and understand the
magnitude of what has been done here you
do not understand when people message me
and say I'm broken I'm shaken I can't
even trust you when people who have
given money are questioning when
people's Iman's have been shaken when
people put their trust in someone and
you've betrayed that on this level of
magnitude where you have waged war on
Allah and His Messenger
I'm not gonna say much I'm not gonna see
much fix up fix up yeah there's a lot of
stuff coming up if always y'all come out
first there's a lot of stuff coming out
my brother yeah there's a lot of stuff
yeah this is your test now Allah says an
or an they believed and then they
disbelieved and then they turned back to
belief and if they turn back in this
belief they will only increase this is
your test yeah if you're gonna come
clean okay an ego get gasket upset why
did I get exposed let's see see what
you're really about cuz right now we do
not trust you yes you claim to be a
Muslim I will take that as face value
yes you are no problem one example of
days and one lie I'm not trying to give
heat on them I'm just trying to make a
point so you guys understand because
this is evident yeah when the sister
said I mean sister Dina came out with y
con Muslim woman marry non-muslim men
please tell me if we was wrong of being
a little bit harsh please tell me
because this is a person who left the
photo a stamp and he admitted with his
own mouth but he was forcing his wife to
disbelief now you come and of course I
prefer le you know sometimes you're
angry you're so harsh around police high
hose you're righteous but do you
understand we were coming from we saw it
with our own eyes now he's claiming that
he forced her into this money and you
don't have no idea we know we know I
can't go into detail my hands are tied
one lipstick sealer I can't
anyways I can't go into what you have no
idea so that's why when something Allah
legislates understand that there's a
reason for it don't get gassed and hyped
and why is it like that what no Allah
and His Messenger send it we take it we
hear and we obey because there's things
that you do not know yeah and that's why
husbands can post their work since what
happened allah subhanaw taala says in
the Quran I would be like min
ash-shaytani r-rajim bismillahi
r-rahmanir-rahim
in surah ideot for 6 in in san a layer
of Billiken old wine a little Shahi
we're in a hotel hi relish Adid Hoffa
yeah la Movida bowl-a-rama fillable
wahoo Salama be sued or in our home be
him yo even la hobby Allah says man
indeed is very ungrateful to his Lord
and he himself is a witness to it and in
his love for wealth
he is very intense does he not then know
what will happen when all that is
contained in the graves will be
overturned and all that is contained in
the hearts will be exposed and all those
things that are in the hearts will be
exposed surely your Lord that day is
fully aware of them Salam alaikum shut
your account repent come to us at Salam
and we're going to help you we will help
you we will help you if you're truly
repentant we will help you